the center of gravity of the global
economy is actually shifting east and
south to some extent in fact what's
interesting about that is that if you
actually try to do a center of gravity
analysis you'll actually find that the
the center of gravity of the global
economy by 2025 will actually be
somewhere in East Asia and what's
interesting about that is that that's
where it was in about year 1 AD as in
fact in some ways it's a return back to
where the center of gravity used to be
so you've got that big geographic shift
happening associated with that same
Geographic shift is actually another
shift which is in some ways even more
interesting which is the the rise in
importance of cities and urbanization I
think for the first time we're going to
see the majority of humanity live in
cities in the ways in ways that are way
more profound than we've ever seen
before in fact of you if you actually
look at the global economy through the
lens of cities you see a few different
things one you see that for example
right you know between now and the year
2025 something like two thirds of the
global economy and the growth in the
global economy is going to be led by
about 600 cities and that's a very
finite number in 600 cities in the in
the grand scheme of things it's not a
very large number and of those 600
cities something like 440 of them are
actually in emerging countries most
people haven't heard of cities like ku
masu Tianjin Honshu so there's a lot of
cities on that list of in the global
economy that are quite extraordinary and
and by the way this rise in urbanization
is interesting because you know we've
actually been adding something the
equivalent of if you like six Chicago's
every year to the global economy in
terms of just the sheer scale of this
urbanization trend we know that people
are wealthier on average when they move
into cities we know that cities as
economic engines are actually more
productive because of that density we
also know now as a result also other
things like technology that some of the
most interesting innovations and
business models and models are actually
happening inside cities so it's no
surprise that the vast majority of some
of the
trends we're seeing whether it's you
know the ubers or the Airbnb s and all
these kinds of a new interesting models
all happen in dense urban environments
so cities are at a very interesting
place and I think we haven't thought
enough about them as sort of engines of
economic growth and performance